how's it going guys my name is Mary here
and I am with Adam from n vibe and we
are checking out a pretty spooky game
called Pamela how's it going at him hey
good good awesome to be here now this is
just the opening story of this game a
creepy survival horror game is it not
yeah so we've just woken up from cryo
sleep here at a brief little intro
sequence there so I've woken up into
this this crowd clinic and I'm gonna
quickly check check my vitals see how
I'm doing here just woke up from car
asleep so I'm a little bit a little bit
thirsty and hungry as you would probably
expect to be so I'm gonna take a look
around the environment here now this
device actually I can use to scan
scanning environment scan the containers
around here found some awesome health
items there I'm gonna quickly give this
room a little a little run through here
so this is a survival game so we need to
make sure we're finding some food and
water is where as we're exploring here
as well as some building items here
which actually found a
ion core here which we can use in a few
minutes to uh to start sampled base for
ourselves
Wow so you have a all-in-one device
there that not only tells you your
health and your needs but it scans the
room and that looks like a shield it
looks like that might be something that
comes in handy later considering the
person to your right looks pretty dead
yes exactly so something something tail
was gone wrong in the City of Eden which
is where we woke up here the citizens
have been afflicted by a terrible
disease that causes this uncontrollable
bone growth
so you'll see half of the citizens have
in turn of these grotesque kind of human
statues and the rest have been kind of
driven mad with pain so we'll probably
encounter a few them as we're making a
way out of here
there's just not a lot of things that
sound worse than bone disease is it
called bone-itis haha it's not called
bone-itis but that's a colloquial name
we can we can go it that sounds horrible
so your bones are growing like without
your control maybe hardening and it
causes extreme pain that's why all these
people are going insane
exactly it slowly transforms muscle into
bone basically it's sort of loosely
based on some real disease
some truly terrible things so yeah we
want to yeah it's it's quite it's quite
a grotesque and terrible terrible things
right and that's setting the foundation
for where we are here but you don't know
that much more beyond that do you know
at this point you know you you were
you're basically dropped into this
environment here and you're free to to
basically explore and you know figure
things out that are your own pace so you
wouldn't really know too much of
actually well we're even talking about
at this point as a you know as the
player and I'm not gonna say too much
more of what the well how all that stuff
happened because that will be a she oh
there we go got a security robot here is
on patrol he's gonna leave me alone why
because he's he's probably looking for
someone else so I haven't actually done
anything to get them to come after me
yet but they will actually go after you
if you if you if you do something to
antagonize them they'll I should be
fighting the other citizens as well so
they're pretty tough enemy so I'm gonna
leave him alone there okay we're not
quite well equipped enough to to fight
that guy he's a nice neutral so as long
as you're on the side of good exactly
leaves you be exactly and they're pretty
tough so I'm not gonna do anything to
change out right now oh I did pick up
one weapon here as relieving so this is
a poison dart gun it actually our
weapons system actually attacked has a
kind of modular system where you attach
these pieces onto this metal device on
your arm there so you can mix and match
different weapons to kind of suit your
playstyle so there's just some more
building items I'm kind of gathering is
for going here I've got some shield
pylon walls as well as a power generator
so it looks like your inventory system
can be maxed out you have looks almost
like the tetris esque form where you
have to fit everything in is that is
that the way it is exactly so yeah
banana
if you exactly so you can actually go in
and you know kind of reorganize things
if you want to kind of you know maximize
your inventories here if you want to be
OCD about it you know you can rotate
some things like that yeah and there's a
limited amount of space so you know you
want to be careful with how your work
especially when you're when you're going
to be making crafting new items like
you're going to see in any kind of
survival game that it becomes a meta
game of what items you keep which ones
you end up throwing away the regret of
not taking as much as you possibly could
so that's really interesting exactly
what kinds of things do you need oh oh
you can't some guy sure I'm gonna hit
these guys some poison darts you
expecting that see the enemies where she
procedurally what procedurally placed
here so you have me playing through this
thing okay okay I'm actually pretty
freaky either run run run I'm gonna grab
my bow god I'm gonna quickly duck in
here okay grab a better weapon how
smarter they can they follow you will
they come in here yeah they'll follow me
um oh my god I'm gonna try and not get
corner than that cuz they're dumped in a
corner in that room okay does your
shield have a cooldown or can you just
hold it up forever it'll actually get
broken down as they attack you so
eventually you have muscle guys coming
at you it'll actually will over time
energy breaks okay which is not good as
you can imagine all right we took him
out I think I was pretty intense yeah
yeah that's good my no we're I think
we're secret
we can get you I still hear some people
answer I'm sure a lot about a lot of
people of are already maybe felt this
way but there's definitely a Bioshock
vibe of this game when you're talking
about kind of exploring a place that
should be beautiful but is terrible and
watching something that could have been
some something wonderful decaying that's
kind of a really nice environment a nice
atmosphere that you've laid out for us
here yeah absolutely
my name is absolutely Bioshock is one of
it's definitely one of the is that a lot
of us on the team are huge fans have you
played all of them I have to say a lot
of people a lot of people bring up
System Shock it's kind of blasphemous to
say I actually haven't played System
Shock but but definitely some of those
influences are in there oh my god okay
clear this place on here where we ramped
up a little bit for the demo here these
are some high level weapons of get roots
of ourselves that's very kind of you
exactly all right so now this place it
cleared out a little bit we set up a
little basics I mean gathering some
supplies has been doing here you know
what kind of supplies of you acquired
yeah so this uh so this year yeah this
is a power transmitter which is
basically like our generator we're in
our building system is a I want to say a
little bit kind of Starcraft inspired in
that we have we have this generator we
can drop down here slot in this power
core and that's actually going to give
us a a kind of power range so now I can
build within this area so I have a few
of these a few of these wall pylons here
which I can drop down and we have a
pretty free-form kind of building system
it's sort of a point-to-point I'm kind
of idea here so we can basically just
drop these two pylons here and that's
gonna build a wall in between there well
you're making yourself a little home
here exactly yeah so are the nature
environment is pretty uh it's it's it's
not you know it's not an open you
kind of feel there for us kind of thing
so we we want to make sure that those
students pretty is pretty flexible so we
can kind of DAP through you know
different different areas here so I've
set up a little a little perimeter here
I'm going to block up this one last
little area just to make sure we're
really safe here great so yeah so now
they've got this little perimeter set up
here I can drop down a few other things
here that's nice a future tent exactly
exactly so it's not too dark yet so
these lights are a little bit a little
bit redundant but I'm gonna drop them
down anyways because it will be dark
soon so we have some lights we can place
here so now that we have this power grid
we can do do a couple different things
in here you also drop down a hydroponics
garden here so these will actually be
able to be used to to grow food
basically so long you play the game the
resources of the environment will wilt
Windell over time because you know
you're you know you're consuming them
the afflicted actually will consume them
as well so the longer you play you're
going to be hard-pressed to find food
the afflicted are eating the very
bananas that you are trying to scrape
together and eat exactly exactly you
know they're just trying to survive in
this environment the same way that you
are even though they've been sort of you
know just figured in their shadows of
their former selves they're still trying
to survive just the same so you know
it's a it's a single-player game but we
want to make the AI you know feel it is
much like you know present members of
this of this environment as much as the
player is right and now we've seen I'm
not really sure exactly where we are but
it looks like some kind of scientist
future laboratory or like nice nice
indoor area but will there be outdoors
as well yeah actually if we if we take a
quick
over over it's getting a little bit dark
so we might be able to see it too well
but we actually have a quite large kind
of koi yard environment out here which
is basically in the center of this this
city so we're actually in one of the
towers now this is the residential tower
mm-hm so if you look out here you can
see you can get a little glimpse it's a
little bit dim outside but you can see
there's this large kind of open quarter
which which will be totally open and
available to explore and there's there's
actually this large kind of circular
structure here in the middle that's a
security outpost so if you want to go
there there's gonna be some higher-level
enemies there's gonna be some pretty
powerful weapons you can you can kind of
scavenge there as well so got a logo of
different areas in the game that will
have will they'll feature their own
kinds of the all kinds of loot there all
kinds of enemies to make it you know
interesting as you're exploring these
new spaces yeah it looks like there's a
lot more to investigate now what's the
end goal of course you want to survive
as long as you can but I mean at the end
of the day once you have your hydroponic
farm going and you got nice walls and
you feel safe and sound I mean why get
up in the morning why even live at all
sure yeah so there's a few things you
can do to continue kind of you know
improving your improving your
survivability there's a couple ways you
can actually gently modify your body so
some of the same things that were so you
know similar in a sort of similar way to
Bosch like you know as you mentioned
earlier you'll actually be able to
modify your own body somewhat to you
know give yourself more health more
endurance stronger resistance to attacks
these kind of things and you'll also be
able to find you know higher level
equipment so these weapons you know we
found here just a couple examples of
some of the things you can find but
there's going to be a huge huge swath of
different bits of equipment that will
actually allow some different playstyles
from sort of a more kind of combat the
focus to even some that focus on stealth
and exploration a little bit more i will
there always be just your standard half
humanoid crazies will there be any kind
of bosses or larger enemies people can
look forward to yeah they're actually
there is a few there's a few tougher
enemies that we that we have in this
demo that I actually haven't run into
yet so we are procedural so there's no
way you can know where they are exactly
I'm just getting a little stats Luther
okay yeah yeah
hungry are you yeah I get getting hungry
here and actually I got some LG crisps
great so we will will eat those that
sounds delicious but yeah there's
there's a give me a few different NPC
factions we can encounter so we already
saw some of the the afflicted the the
sort of standard I'm in enemy and and
the seekers which is the security robots
those are two the factions that are in
the game but there also be a couple that
we haven't we haven't quite talked about
yet but they're going to be they're
gonna be kind of wildcards so they'll
sort of be hostile towards a you know
towards the other guys so they can
actually be again fighting with the
afflicted so you can sort of get in the
middle of some of these confrontations
in certain you can choose one as well or
yeah some what I mean they have the
different factions with a without you
know saying too much they they have
their own you know kind of which ones
evil you know there's always an evil
faction yeah well they're kind of all
you know they're a little bit evil
they're a little bit you know just
fighting for themselves you know what
you know they're just uh you know
they're trying to survive this is their
city actually though we kind of woke up
so we're sort of you know we're almost
the bad guys in this situation
interested you're invading on their
territory now yeah a little bit oh you
know that's actually tough family up
there okay the series Frank alone
they're gonna try to it looks like a
multiple looks like there's a few yeah
there's a couple here yikes
oh god he's got quit arms yes he does
actually so he's a that's a more that's
more heavily heavily afflicted so he's
actually got some more heavy deformation
going on okay jaws kind of hanging their
arms or split he's really he's a really
tough guys we try to make sure let's get
hit
yeah we've had like genetic splicing
yeah a little bit
toes he's got webbed feet he's got a
corner here Oh God
now what happens when you get seriously
injured is there a way to get more
health up yeah I'm actually the key oh
yeah actually just just use the med hypo
there so we actually were lucky fine
while those in starting area so so we
don't have that we don't have too much
anyway for generating health into this
code here all right that that went well
good yeah we don't have too much in the
way of regenerating health food doesn't
regen health stops you from being hungry
yeah you know we might you know when
you're full health info hunger we might
you know give you a slight kind of
health regen but depends how depends on
less we want to be I suppose yeah this
is a not done and this is you guys are
still balancing and tweaking this
exactly and it's supposed to be a fairly
a fairly intense and you know
challenging experience you know its a
permadeath game so we want to maintain
that sort of you know that consistent
level of challenge intention yeah that's
an interesting choice that you guys made
to make this perma death it adds
obviously just a way more intense level
of difficulty to this game now you guys
are starting from scratch every time but
once you die and you start over from
scratch you don't get any of your items
you're basically a hundred percent start
over there's no forgiveness here yeah
so basically there'll be a few kind of
response point s kind of things you can
sort of uncover in the environment that
can give you you know maybe like one
extra life sort of things so if you find
one these places you you might be able
to respond actually find your items on
your body basically wherever you died
but
speaking you're pretty much gonna be
starting from scratch if you buy but
that being said we we're looking at
having some kind of sort of persistent
leveling system so you you do get some
points towards when you start your next
character you might be able to get you
know a little bit more health or a
little bit more you know endurance or
something with your next character so
you know not not too much because we do
want it to revolve around you know
looting and each life you know is
different than the last but at the same
time you know people people do like be
able to feel like they made some
progress you get you know totally
totally killed early on how long can you
expect to actually survive like how long
would a really good player be able to
function in this world I mean when you
first start of course you're gonna have
five-minute playthroughs when you get
absolutely destroyed right away but I
mean how long would you expect people to
be able to survive once they've once
they've acquired a you know maybe some
bonuses to their characters and they
know where to find stuff and they know
what they're doing yeah I mean you could
I would expect like I mean may I hope
hopefully many you know many hours
eventually you know it's it is it's a
pretty freeform game so you know I think
different people are can latch on to
different aspects of it but you know
when it comes to like you know building
your base and trying to find the
absolute best equipment you know I'd
like to think that you know play through
could you know could go easily you know
five to ten hours kind of thing if
you're able to you know able to survive
that long at you really want to uncover
you know every nook and cranny and you
know and we're gonna be adding more to
the game as well like we were initially
you know gonna be looking at release
kind of later on the summer kind of
thing but you know we have a lot of
plans for a different you know different
areas and different weapons and things
like that that we did we want to be
adding after the fact we have a you know
we have a plan so we'll see how far we
get with that but alright I know do you
sleep to regen anything like what are
you doing here now that it's nighttime
and you're pretty safe for the evening
yeah sure so yeah you would be able to
see if I'm actually found a bed here but
you would you'd be able to sleep and
actually pass the night so you could
kind of wake up and you know see see
some light again but does that help with
your health does it help with anything
sleeping yeah exactly you would
regenerate some health that a bit of a
bit of a kind of hyung
you know hunger and thirst cost
basically is you know you're gonna be
tired you know you wake in the morning
or you're hungry but your health is
perjuring of it so one less thing we'll
take a look at here is our power system
so I just interface here that I can I
can draw power from like the main the
main city's power grid basically I'm
actually dying you're dying I'm dying I
know I'm dehydrated offensive food oh
yeah you're thirsty oh my god no I'm
dying here and it's gonna give way to
end a half I don't know but anyone can
find a lemon or something yeah anyway
before I die here you can see the we've
uh we've turned on the power here now so
we've got some light got some lights
you're a little bit better visibility
going on oh no it's not my shame this is
not looking good
see there you go women that's the nature
of the game though I mean I'd you know
oh you know I found some milk all right
there we go oh that was a close one
that's really stressful all right I'm
gonna plug this parch now so no you I'm
not dying I'm not great at it but we're
we're summer in the middle trash can
milk too like there's no way that milk
is yeah yeah then it's gone bad it's
probably not great but I mean it's like
some sci-fi future not you know I feel
like some special you know preservatives
inner something and and without giving
away too much because obviously a lot of
this game is about exploration and
figuring out what happened here is there
any tidbits you can give me about the
lore or this world and why you're here
and what you're doing yeah sure so the
the city is called Eden it's a sort of
utopian society that actually is used to
be UCS or use of utopian society that
was out on the tear right is Oh God
oh yeah yeah statue guy you can see he's
got this he's basically turned to human
statues as bones and sort of solidified
oh my god horrible sure something
happened these people to make them
freak out yeah yeah so the fallen
through the wallet Claudius when I quit
setup probably I guess um but yeah so
but the city used to be this utopian
society that's basically floating on the
ocean it's sort of this self-sustaining
society that actually holds power from
the Sun and the ocean so it basically
was like this kind of self-regenerating
it's beautiful no yeah this is this huge
huge Tower and I know got a lot of he
had never actually looked up this but a
lot of verticality going on here in lo
the snow that's sweet um yeah so I mean
you you basically wake up and something
obviously has gone terribly wrong but
you know you of course this point the
game you really have no idea what's
going on so you know as you explore you
can find tidbits on you know people's
lot talk to the things like that you can
actually you know get glimpses as to to
what might have actually happened it
seems like there's a lot to unpack and I
I'd love to get into this world and
learn a lot more about it so when can
people expect to play this game yes we
have a sentence don't really say yet but
where we're aiming for kind of a later
late summer kind of early fall sort of
launched this summer and that'll be on
the and they'll be on Steam on PC and
you have a plans to go anywhere else
besides PC you know not at this point on
this is actually our first game a studio
so we're we're kind of setting our
sights realistically that not stretch
ourselves too thin
but we we would love to bring the game
to consoles you know probably after the
PC release a lot of people been asking
about it so we definitely wanna make it
happen so as many people can enjoy the
game as possible sweet well thanks for
showing me that enim yeah absolutely is
great being here yep so that was pamela
guys and you guys can look forward to
that later on this summer and you can
find it on Steam